hey guys my name is Jessa McDonald it's
the 17th the jalaj day and you're tuned
into a Thursday edition of GameSpot news
it's pretty much the same with all our
other editions except on Thursday not a
good intern in very sad news it turns
out the rumors were true and Microsoft
will be cutting 18,000 jobs over the
next year 12 and a half thousand of the
layoffs will come from the nokia devices
and services unit i hear-- microsoft
acquired last yeah ZDNet reported
earlier in the week that the Xbox
division would be affected and now it
seems it is resulting in the closure of
Xbox entertainment studios this is the
division who are focused on developing
original video programming including the
halo TV series and halo nightfall
despite the closure those projects will
go on as planned p 18 thousand cuts
represent the largest in the company's
history and as the company employs
127,000 people that's about a fourteen
percent reduction our thoughts go out to
everybody affected by the layoffs the
destiny beta is alive and kicking and
although Xbox users will get their hands
on it next week it turns out it won't be
coming to Xbox one in 1080p Bungie have
stressed that there is always room for
improvement though and as community
manager David dave says the fact that
you're playing in the beta is of
enormous help to us because it teaches
us what the thing is it teaches us how
we can perfect it and make it better
before launch we are aiming for 1080p on
all platforms they also explained that
what gamers have available to them is a
true and rough beta and not an early
sneak peek into the game well it seems
that maybe nobody loves the kinect after
microsoft announced that the xbox one
doubled its sales after dropping the
camera peripheral the company have
claimed that sales of the Xbox one in
the u.s. more than doubled since its
release on jun 9 in comparison to sales
in mate if you're wondering what the
specifics are for this one well so are
we we weren't ever given the sales
figures for me nor have we been updated
with overall figures games what is
currently in touch with Microsoft to get
more specifics on that one as for your
question of the day
do let me know down in the comments
whether you think the xbox one without
connect will have sold enough to match
up to the ps4 sales figures or not those
are all the things I want to tell you
about today but tomorrow do you remember
I'll be back with my top five stories of
the whole entire week so I do hope to
see you been